[Music]
so I would in which I wanted not only to
look at infidelity from the point of
view of the impact and the consequences
but also from the point of view of the
meanings and the motives why do people
do this why do people who often have
been faithful for decades when they
cross the line they never thought they
would cross what's at stake how do we
make sense of this how do we grow from
that can it ever become an opportunity
can a couple ever glean something that
ultimately may strengthen it rather than
only seeing it from the point of view of
the Cataclysm and to write a book where
I try to understand infidelity doesn't
mean that I'm justifying it and when one
doesn't condemn it it doesn't mean that
one is condoning it but this experience
affects so many people I have worked
with hundreds thousands of people who
have been shattered by the experience of
infidelity and I thought there needs to
be a better way that is more caring and
more compassionate for the crisis that
so many people face so at the heart of
affairs what does it what is infidelity
is the question people often ask me how
do i define it and interestingly there
is no universally agreed-upon definition
of infidelity and in fact in the
definition keeps on expanding with the
advent of the digital you know what is
it is it staying secretly active on your
dating apps is it watching porn is it
but but not but not when the other
person is live is it massage with happy
endings where is the lines there has
never been it's never been easier to
cheat and it's never been more difficult
to keep a secret
so this diffuseness is very much at the
heart of trying to define it but there
are three elements that are always
present and the more important one is
the constitutive element of an affair is
the fact that it is organized around a
secret the structure of infidelity is
its secrecy that is why it is such a
major difference from the conversation
about
Gnomeo consensual and monogamy those are
two separate realities so an affair is
organized around the structured element
called secret second element is that
there is a sexual aura an alchemy not
necessarily the presence of sex itself
it's not the bodily experiences it's the
energy much more than the performance
and three that there is an emotional
involvement to one degree or another
from a deep love affair to even a
transaction in which one pays for the
other person to leave but there is
always a meaning to it that is what I
call the emotional involvement even when
you try to mean make something mean
nothing it means a lot our current model
of thinking says if you have found the
one and only it means that you're
willing to forego everything else for
that person and you no longer miss
anything else if you have everything you
need there is no need to go looking
elsewhere if you have gone to look
elsewhere
there must be something missing either
there's something missing in you or in
your relationship we are very wet today
to looking at infidelity and
transgressions from a symptom
perspective it's the symptom model there
must be something wrong but I often was
thinking that millions of people can't
all be pathological so if it is not the
case that it is always a symptom what is
it and one of the great discoveries and
surprises in my research for the state
of affairs was to notice that people
would come and say I love my partner I'm
having an affair that sometimes people
even in satisfying relationships also
strain and they don't stray because they
are rejecting their relationship or
because they are reacting to their
relationship but they often stray not
because they want to find another person
but because they want to reconnect with
a different version of themselves it
isn't so much that they want to leave
the person that they are with as much as
sometimes they want to leave the person
that they have themselves become
and what when reads in the book is that
the more parts of yourself you can bring
into a relationship the less likely you
may then be to go looking for the lost
parts elsewhere and that's when I began
to say even people in happy
relationships cheat as well it isn't
always about the other or about the
relationship at the heart of affairs you
will find betrayal and lying and
deception and loss but you will also
find yearning and longing and
self-discovery and that's an exploration
and it is those two experiences that
make this most complex conundrum of
infidelity what it did to you and what
it meant for me